hey guys quick note my brand new book
the authoritarian moment is out
this week go pick up a copy today i
think it's really important
it's about how all of the major
institutions of american society have
now been
taken over and weaponized by the left
against dissent
it's not just about how they did it it's
about how we take those institutions
back
check out the link in the description
below and get a copy of the
authoritarian moment
is simone biles a hero or is she a
villain these apparently are the only
two sides you can take in the
ongoing simone biles controversy so
apparently
what happened with simone biles
according to the new york times simone
biles lost her way midair while vaulting
in the women's team final in the
olympics on tuesday
then suddenly exited the competition
saying she wasn't mentally prepared to
compete
biles's absence created a bigger opening
for the russians who won the gold
apparently she uh she started propelling
herself in the air
and then she sort of got lost in the air
uh
and she ended up landing on her feet but
she was completely lost
in the air minutes later usa gymnastics
confirmed biles had withdrawn from the
competition leaving the us without its
highest scoring gymnast
bile said i just felt like it would be a
bit better to take a backseat and work
on my mindfulness
i didn't want to risk the team of metal
for kind of my screw-ups because they've
worked
way too hard for that and
it really did hurt the team i mean like
her her vault was really really bad
for the team and probably because of
that the team was denied the gold
so her case was i lost it i wanted to
exit before i i lost it worse
and then everybody missed out on the
silver here with simone biles describing
her withdrawal from the olympics of
course she is widely considered the
greatest
gymnast of all time because she's done
things in competition that nobody else
has even attempted
to focus on my well-being and you know
there's more to
life than just gymnastics and it is very
unfortunate that it has to happen
at this stage because i definitely want
to miss a little bit better
put mental health first because if you
don't then
you're not going to enjoy your sport and
you're not going to succeed as much as
you want to so it's okay sometimes to
even set out the big competitions
to focus on yourself because it shows
how strong of a competitor and person
that you really are
okay well that last part where it's okay
to sit out the big competitions
to focus in on who you are and your
mindfulness
what you should have said is i was
suffering aerial disorientation
i lost my ability to know where i was in
the air and that's dangerous right
that would actually be understandable
but but the way that she is phrasing
that obviously
is uh is not super understandable that i
lost
my mindfulness was lost and you need to
sit out and take care of who you are
um okay so a couple of things some
people on the right
have been blasting simone biles
including people i'm friends with you
know clay travis for example
has been going after some mobiles and
saying you know she choked here
and by the way by any sports standard
she did
right she's a competitor every every
competitor in sport
and and every other area of life is a
competitor and also a person so you can
understand where they're coming from
personally if they withdraw from a
competition
but it is fair to say that if lebron
james were in game seven of the nba
finals and after quarter one he said you
know i just don't have it today
i don't have it i'm out i'm gonna leave
this team they're on their own
people would say like whoa that that is
a massive choke by
la flop right that would have been that
would have been the way that people
treated it
male athletes aren't treated this way if
tom brady did that in the super bowl he
threw a couple interceptions in the
first quarter he said okay i'm throwing
it into my backup
everybody would be like wow that is a
massive all-time pull-out choke
okay now what she was doing here is
if she was trying to preserve her own
health like if this was actually
dangerous that is a different thing
but it doesn't make you a hero for
pulling out and this is why you are
seeing people bouncing off each other
with regard to simone biles so on the
one side you have people saying
well she's not a hero and on the other
side they're saying well she's not a
villain and the answer is kind of
somewhere in between
you're right she's not a hero and she's
also not a villain here was a fox news
host called uh
or a fox sports host named doug gottlieb
going after biles yesterday
if we're okay with simone biles saying
hey couldn't go tonight
mental health we can be okay if lebron
says the same thing
she's the greatest gymnast going he's
the greatest basketball player going
why do we have sympathy for simone biles
but we wouldn't have sympathy
or empathy for lebron james it's called
double standard
right and you get people saying like man
there's simone biles and naomi osaka
they take so much abuse on social media
no they don't okay so when it comes to
the the sort of bravery point it is it
is amazing how again bravery has shifted
bravery is now authenticity you're the
bravest person
not if you do something for your
teammates not if you do something
for your country you're the bravest if
you find yourself if you find your inner
peace that is true bravery bravery
and decency all of it lies in
authenticity
that is not a real standard for bravery
it isn't
and again this doesn't mean she's a
villain but it also doesn't mean she's a
hero and yet the media insists on
treating simone biles pulling out in the
same way they treated naomi osaka
pulling out of the french open this is
an act of heroism no
it isn't can it just be something that
human beings do without it being
valorized and treated as an act of
heroism can we just do that
like why is in between such a bad place
to be for most human beings
there are a couple of opinion pieces
that have decided that it is not merely
just
a thing that simone biles dropped out of
the olympics she's heroic
for having dropped out of the olympics
and this is the part i i really don't
understand this
doesn't make any sense to me so you have
a piece from lindsey krause in the new
york times title simone biles doesn't
need a gold medal to win
well again she she pulled out of a team
competition
as the highest scoring gymnast in
history
so i'm not sure how that's winning
we have a different definition of
winning now quote as we head into the
2021 olympics
i have often recalled being a 12 year
old watching the american olympic
gymnast at the 1996 atlanta games vault
and soren flipped their way to victory
those girls were just a little older
than me but they were so small you could
see their muscles moving under their
skin
i regarded them with awe but thinking of
them now i also cringe
they were hurting themselves as america
cheered dominic marciano later said she
was often limited to 900 calories a day
during competition and she competed in
atlanta on a fractured tibia
carries strugg struck her celebrated
vault on a torn ankle
on the metal podium the girls stood
together solemnly like soldiers the
message
the message to girls like me was clear
being the best takes pain
okay why is that a terrible message like
that's very often true in sport like i'm
that doesn't mean that you should have
your dog like i wouldn't have my
daughter
living on 900 calories a day but that
does happen to be the case
athletes often undergo physical stress
that normal people don't undergo which
is why their bodies are torn up by the
time they're 35
right 35 is considered very old in
athletic competition that is considered
very young in any other area of your
career
this columnist says gymnastics has
historically been a showcase for a
certain
type of femininity we reward girls who
are small pretty and compliant who smile
disarmingly and don't complain while
winning
well i mean what what would we reward
gymnast for
being large non-mobile and grumpy
that'd be weird gymnastics a sport rife
with abuse of all varieties has been a
microcosm of what happens to
extraordinary little girls when they
grow up
they get discarded again all of this is
in preparation for saying that simone
biles is a hero for dropping out of
competition which again is a stretch
i like to imagine a 12 year old at home
today watching simone biles command the
mat
biles the reigning u.s national champion
arguably the greatest gymnast of all
time shows it doesn't have to be like
this after all
in a sport where you can begin to age
out by the time you're old enough to
vote
biles is 24 and at the top of her game
her recent performances have been
nothing short of astounding with that
status biles is forging a new model
for one of america's most popular female
sports not as a pre-pubescent girl but
as an athletic
young woman she posts photos of pizza to
her instagram she posts her bathing
suits and boyfriends too she wears
leotards with little rhinestone goats
for greatest of all time
she has she's dismantling unhealthy
notions of what it takes to succeed
and how a female champion is allowed to
look on the madden off she is redefining
female power
in sports um she with
drew though i mean maybe this column was
written before she went through
but i'm just but then they shouldn't run
the column
because that's weird in fact
they actually add a little addendum to
the piece in which lindsey kraus says
quote
usa gymnastics announced on july 27th
biles had pulled out of the olympic team
because of a medical issue
even without a gold medal biles has
proved it time and time again she
remains
the best ever the olympics may have
outsized importance in the public eye
but ultimately they're just another set
of medals
oh okay meanwhile over at the washington
post same thing from alyssa rosenberg
quote
the most dramatic image at the tokyo
olympics thus far wasn't the spectacle
of the opening ceremonies or a photo
finish in the pool
rather it was the crooked line of simone
biles's tightly sealed lips as she
walked to the sidelines after a
disappointing vault performance
in the gymnastics team all-around
competition
on tuesday biles withdrew from that
contest and has not yet decided whether
she'll proceed with other events
it's a development that upends one of
the biggest stories of the games
the idea the olympics pit the best
against the best has always been more
dream than reality
whether it's geopolitical competition a
pandemic or simple bad luck that keeps
some athletes out of competition but
every blow against that ideal of a
perfect meritocracy is heartbreaking
yet if anything good can come out of
biles's withdrawal and naomi osaka's
early elimination from the women's
tennis competition
it would be this maybe we fans can learn
to embrace more expansive definitions
of excellence and courage you mean then
winning
see the thing that's appealing about
sports is that there's a pretty obvious
binary
get the winners and the losers and
it doesn't mean the losers are bad
people but they did lose and that is how
we judge
whether somebody has won or lost but we
we keep doing this in society now it's
like if a comedian isn't funny we have
to redefine our notion of what comedy is
if a gymnast that we want to treat as
heroic
pulls out of competition then we have to
redefine our notion of what winning
is how about we we don't really find any
of those things
we just say that simone bile's lost or
that she withdrew
why can't we just say that and not
redefine basic notions what it means to
win
or lose the tearing down of standards
because we like a person is a very odd
message in in today's society for sure
says alyssa rosenberg rooting for biles
to dominate the tokyo olympics has long
been about more than the us's medal
count her greatness has redefined the
very contours of her sport
in addition to her athletic excellence
biles has hoisted
heavy symbolic burdens onto her four
foot eight inch frame
biles has been a role model for black
girls in a predominantly white sport
her excellence has served as a rebuke to
usa gymnastics which failed to protect
her and her teammates from the
predations of larry nassar she moved
from nike to athleta in search of a
sponsor that would help her fun an
independent exhibition tour
despite the betrayals she has
experienced and the exhaustion and pain
she feels according to juliet macra in
the new york times quote biles has
managed to set aside those feelings and
harness the newfound power of an
independent black woman
who knows her worth and answers to no
one
again i i just don't what
but she she quit i mean like
that's okay she she's allowed
particularly if she was in danger
but why is that better i just want like
is that better than the alternative of
her winning
a gold is that better than the
alternative for sticking around and
gutting it out
i don't know why alyssa rosenberg
concludes sports may strike blows
against deals like racism and
individuals can deliver
biting reprimands to institutions but
athletes can't do the painful work of
social change alone
and their only tools aren't perfectly
executed vaults or dominant tennis sets
there can be greatness too in saying no
why i just don't but why
well well it's not great to say no it's
mediocre to say no
end of story not great not horrific
just mediocre and again if she withdrew
for reasons other than danger then it is
bad right if she just withdrew because
she wasn't up for it that day then she
let her teammates down in the same way
that any other person in a team sport
lets their teammates down
if they're quote-unquote just not up for
it that day if it's aerial if it's
aerial disorientation different thing
because
that'd be like michael jordan pulling
out of a game in the nba finals because
he actually has the flu
but here's the thing if michael jordan
pulled out of the nba finals because he
had the flu
then he wouldn't be a hero for doing
that he was a hero in that game
in the famous flu game because michael
jordan played through the flu
to be the hero you have to overcome the
obstacle if you if the obstacle
overcomes you
that doesn't make you a hero and it
doesn't make a villain just makes you a
human end of story
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video